how's it going whoa
the stream just started and it's John
John gifting 100 subs that's probably
more that's war subs and people watching
the stream thanks so much John welcome
back John hope you're doing well
my last was it Blast two out of three
YouTube videos or games against John one
of them was actually both both the
videos featuring John also featured all
I want to do in the title
there is fork stuff there is pin stuff
all John wants to do because this is
gifts subs thanks so much let's play a
game not some goo do I play the bot
let's play human actually let's play a
random challenge everyone challenging me
to blitz casual beautiful hey and we
have Brigham Brigham Aldrich finally
watching on twitch and not YouTube
welcome to twitch to play outfit for I
too high I lower myself I don't know if
that's better okay it's candy time
well Carlson played this other day
you've Austin eighteen moves but he
played oh actually white plate Knight f3
that game so we have a queen G it's
candy
so this person's probably oh this person
I I recognize a team actually that's
team's candy just scrap thanks for
subbing
as reside welcome back centralizing
tonight oh no like Queen my queen I
forgot how to play chess it's been so
long that mmm-hmm my most recent video
is all about pins
I broke the pin I think my opponents
probably high rated enough
so it's not not walk into this also a 95
was not the best move but it's paying
off can take a bishop oh no my queen my
queen then the knight defends the Queen
okay okay thanks for the game I was
eight moves so if at first oh no my
queen doesn't succeed I always have to
try again that probably goes on YouTube
I was like a double oh no my queen I
should explain though that I think
Bishop digs f7 is objectively the best
move here because it winds up one by
force if after it takes yeah
takes takes takes everything is happy
for whites
well black should have done is play
Bishop e6 there's a v6 I think holds on
to things white still better here but I
don't think likes winning upon anyway
thanks for the game see c-13 be numbers
and YouTube people that was a quick one
hope you enjoyed that this will probably
be uploaded so what's today today is
Thursday I'll probably upload this
Saturday so happy happy weekend to the
YouTube people don't forget to Like and
subscribe
almost hitting 90,000 subscribers I
might do something special maybe I'll do
like a Swiss tournament anyway yeah have
a good day